kristen is in charleston south carolina
hi kristen what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
hey um so i just sold my house today i
made um
21 000 profit from it and um
this is the most money i've ever had my
whole life and i
want to put it directly into my savings
account but i just wanted
advice on how i can continue to be in a
good financial position
and not be tempted to spend any of it
congratulations how old are you thank
you
i'm 25. how long have you owned this
house
since 2017. all right you did good
i can hear her joy through the phone
yeah it's exciting for you
a nice twenty one thousand dollar check
send me twenty one thousand i'll get
joyful like
all day long yeah that's good so uh
where are you gonna live
well right now um i'm renting an
apartment with the roommate
um but i plan what the lease has done to
um buy my own house again
once the what is done once the lease is
over with uh with the apartment
um starting next year i plan on buying
my own house again
okay so you weren't living in this house
oh yes i was living in the house how
come you sold it
i unfortunately i separated from my
fiance
um so the money was split in half
and um balancing with a roommate um and
until this lease is done
um i would like to buy my own house
that's perfect
i love it okay and so um well here's
what you do you you uh
you can just keep it in a bank account
that's all you need to do nothing fancy
uh ask for your ask your local banker or
your credit union to open you a money
market account
do not connect it to overdraft
protection
on your checking account do not
connect it to your atm card
do not have access to it unless you go
to the branch
and pull money out that will keep you
from accidentally impulsing when you see
a
couch on sale on the weekend right
and so you build some protections and
make it a little bit hard to get it get
to it does that make sense
yes sir that makes perfect sense yeah do
you understand if it's connected to your
checking account you're going to have a
tendency to i want to buy something and
i'll just keep writing checks right
right and if if you're atm the same way
so just
protect you from you which is what
you're concerned about but the good news
is you're already aware of that so
you're very unlikely to make this
mistake
how long have you been how long have you
been separated
um about two months okay so i would
set up with your roommate is this a
friend of yours
yes yes it is okay come up with some
number
because this grief is going to wave over
you like being out
at the beach okay and it will wave over
in different seasons and at weird
moments you're going to be walking in
from somewhere
after having a great time and it's just
you're going to feel like someone just
dropped one of those heavy blankets over
you okay
i want you to have some sort of
agreement with your roommate that you
will check in before you make a purchase
over x dollars
is that cool and that would be your
accountability partner through this
grieving process because i don't want
you to use
you you're gonna have 21 thousand
dollars singing the count
and like dave said it's going to be so
tempting just to
to go get that dopamine hit and feel
better go to the bank and
you're just going to have to get a new
car or have to get a new designer
oodle dog or some kind of something go
on some vacation whatever it is
have have an accountability partner that
you got to check in with
okay i'll give you the number anything
over 300
you have to check in how's your relation
how's your relationship with your mom
and dad
oh that's pretty decent okay you might
also have that
agreement with them then okay
and that's not you not being an adult
that's just somebody that loves you
that's kin to you right that you can
check in with that's not that you have
to ask your mommy
that's not my point but my point is same
thing john's doing is giving you
accountability
and so um one last thing i don't get to
do this very often would you mind
helping me with something
yeah sure would you talk to the audience
out there because i catch a lot of grief
when i tell people not to buy a house
with people they're not married to
because crap like happened to you
happens
would you talk to people out there that
are thinking about making the same
mistake you did when you bought this
house with this goob
well um my advice would just be um
make sure this is the person you know
you want to spend the rest of your life
with and make sure
my advice is to get married that would
be my advice
yeah because you thought you were going
to spend the rest of your life
right i was 21 when i built this house
and um i i wish i would have
you know i i think it would have been a
lot easier if i was married
um and
that would be my advice yeah don't do
don't buy a house with people you're not
married to
that's what i tell people all the time
and people sometimes that are your age
make fun of me because i'm an old
grandpa
uh but that's but it's also i have met
with over the 30 years of doing coaching
i've met with thousands of people
in your situation and not you know the
good news is the house sold
and you're able to make money you made
money and you're able to split the money
and you're able to get away from this
problem
and get out of what a lawyer would call
a partnership
yeah a general partnership with no
partnership documentation and so it
turned out okay in the end you made it
out with your skin intact and made a
little money
but to go with the heartbreak you have
to go with this disposition of assets
as if there's a divorce and yet there is
no legal track to run the thing on
the last thing you want to do when
you're grieving is math right yup
that's the that's the last thing you
want to do man yeah that's exactly right
whether you don't have
life insurance you don't have any number
of things man yeah
thank you christian thank you kirsten
kirsten i'm sorry for for
sharing that but it's this is the reason
it it doesn't
always turn out like you think it's
going to so get things in the right
order don't buy a house until you're
married
with someone you are not married to um
and so again she got blessed and got out
of it without a problem and i'm happy
she did i didn't i didn't want her to be
punished
or something like that but i am uh she
said
you know 21 years old yeah
and um and like we talked about earlier
in a previous segment
you got it all figured out when you're
21 right and you're 41
and when you're 51 and when you're 61. i
have and i i if i have
on a much smaller scale i know you have
man talking to folks in that same
situation who are trying to split
debt oh it's harsh it's it's a it's
mayhem
yeah you couldn't you couldn't have that
conversation beforehand which led to
this
you know breakup trying to figure out
who's going to take what debt and how
you're going to split when you bought
this on that credit card and you bought
that
and the house we have to write a check
for it remember that time you use the
mustard
dude it gets contentious and messy yeah
it's it's it's like it's like breaking
up with your roommate oh because you are
yeah yeah it's just uh yeah it's a real
problem
and we're seeing it at a a pandemic
level
but yeah too soon man it's an epidemic
anyway it may not be a pandemic but it's
definitely an epidemic so
well kirsten i'm glad you got out uh and
you got some money i appreciate the
smile on your face for the twenty one
thousand that's
what a win and you needed a win i'm glad
you got the win
and uh we want you to have a a wonderful
purchase of a home when that uh money's
all still sitting there
and you've added some to it still in the
account and it's still in the account
you've added some to it
and uh your lease runs out and you're
able to do that so most excellent very
cool
thank you for joining us kiddo